que va-t-il se passer sur cette chaîne
les gens seuls demande voilà on m'arrête
dans la rue les journalistes m'arrête
les gens se réunissent en secret pour
élaborer des théories du complot suis-je
roumain suis-je reptilien voilà tout le
monde en parle y en a marre maintenant
je vais répondre à la question qui est
que va-t-il se passer sur cette chaîne
et oui un petit peu quels sont les
prochains projets je ne peux pas tout
vous dire parce qu'il ya des petits
secrets encore n'est-ce pas théorie du
complot reptilien jeu vient d'une autre
planète
on va commencer avec le plus gros projet
là qui va arriver pas pour tout de suite
mais plutôt pour la rentrée c'est mon
prochain court-métrage le voici voilà
c'est 20 pages d'une nouvelle aventure
c'est pas pour tout de suite parce qu'il
ya pas mal de préparation le casting les
des cordes par l équipe va pas mal de
jours de tournage
j'espère que ça va vous plaire c'est
assez différent de l'unr c'est assez
différent de décines - d'alien j'ai
envie d'essayer des nouvelles histoires
c'est un peu plus sérieux j'expérimente
j'expérimente parce que je suis rien
voilà je ne vois que cette explication
vous l'avez peut-être remarqué mais
derrière moi il ya un nouveau studio
voilà c'est le studio de ma chaîne
gaming avec squeeze et en fait on a pris
le nom on l' a explosé comme ça et ça
s'appelle désormais bigorneaux et
coquillages pourquoi je ne saurais
l'expliquer tout est parti très vite en
couille le nom c'est ça il faudra
s'habituer
je sais pas pourquoi [ __ ] on n'a même
pas spécialement les fruits de mer je
sais pas pourquoi ça comme ça et bien
sûr on reprend cette chaîne avec des
sortes de petits défis et vlog on essaye
des véhicules en fait tout est n'importe
quoi c'est chaque semaine donc n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
fait je fais ça mais je sais pas si ce
sera qui captait dans la description
dans la description vous pouvez cliquer
sur bigoni cocker et enfin il y à leur
tour d'un très gros projet ça fait
depuis le début de l'année que je bosse
dessus c'est le retour de ma série audio
de l'été l'épopée temporel j'ai reçu
beaucoup de messages de gens qui
voulaient la suite ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir la nouvelle saison
de l'épopée temporaire revient j'ai eu
aussi des messages qui m'ont fait très
plaisir en fait les gens avouer que la
série audio c'était pas trop leur délire
et me disaient mais en fait sans image
vois pas pourquoi je vais écouter ce
truc là et finalement j'ai écouté un ou
deux épisodes et j'ai tout écouté et je
veux savoir la suite voilà ce genre de
messages ont fait très plaisir merci à
vous les gars de croire en ce que je
fais même si ça peut être un peu étrange
au premier abord comme ça donc
je vous aime j'ai aussi reçu des
messages arrête avec tes histoires
étaient courts métrages je préfère les
podcasts sur l'école voilà ça c'est ma
vie aujourd'hui ce genre de message les
gars c'était un kif énorme de faire la
première saison l'année dernière qui a
fait plus de 20 millions de vues c'est
incroyable c'est normal finalement pour
facile de la suite qui revient dès jeudi
dès après demain sur ma chaîne youtube
toutes les semaines cet été alors dans
cette nouvelle saison les épisodes sont
plus longs et va y avoir des guest aussi
du genre
antoine daniel françois damiens il va y
avoir des nouvelles musiques composées
des nouveaux personnages une nouvelle
intrigue des nouvelles illustrations on
a enregistré pendant dix jours avec une
vingtaine de comédiens c'était mortel
vous pouvez écouter la nouvelle saison
sans forcément avoir écouté la première
voilà y'a pas de problème vous pouvez
comprendre l'histoire mais c'est quand
même un petit peu plus qu'ils font et
puis les épisodes sont gratuits sur ma
chaîne youtube vous voulez découvrir dès
à présent c'est parfait pour l'été avec
les petits écouteurs comme ça ou au
travail si vous faites semblant de
travailler et vous pouvez regarder aussi
les illustrations sur la chaîne youtube
avec des illustrateurs qui sont comme ça
certes on les mange on mange les
illustrateurs nom très très bon cela je
suis très fier du résultat donc j'espère
que ça va vous plaire j'ai hâte que ça
sorte
et enfin il ya pas mal d'autres projets
qui sont en préparation de sketches
podcasts et des trucs qui sont en dehors
de ma chaîne youtube mais je peux pas
trop vous en parler gros suspense de
bâtard je vous cache des choses théorie
du complot dont résumait c'est le retour
de ma chaîne secondaire si plein gaming
qui s'appelle désormais bigorneaux et
coquillages est aussi un épisode par
semaine sur la chaîne youtube de
l'épopée temporel master audio de l'été
et d'autres projets un petit peu
mystérieux notamment un court métrage
qui vont arriver à la rentrée
[Musique]